[Musique]
dépêchez-vous les enfants si vous voulez
faire une surprise à nounours j'entends
le chant du pipeau du marchand de sable
ils arrivent
des fleurs moi je lui dirai ma poésie
oui
[Musique]
non j'ai pas le moment de mettre du
désordre va plutôt aider
tiens
oh ce sont des pommes de pin mais c'est
tout ce qu'il y a comme fleurs dans la
neige oh elle en a acheté partout cette
petite
bonsoir les enfants
nous sommes bien contents de revenir
vous voir et nous ours est très pressé
de retrouver tous ces petits amis oh oui
alors je me demande si Pépita est
cornichon ont été sages pendant notre
absence voyons pas trop vous savez bien
que oui mais moi je descends vite les
voir mon échelle
oh mais elle est jolie allons petite
échelle il faut habituer au froid de la
montagne
[Musique]
le montant que c'est tout ce qu'on
trouve et des proches de pain de belles
branches de pain
bonsoir mes amis
vous êtes très attendu mon cher nounours
moi aussi j'avais hâte de vous revoir
tous
pour toi ou les balles bronches ce que
je suis gâté
vas-y cornichon
je suis plus très bien je t'écoute
j'adore les poèmes là
[Musique]
il me semble qu'il y a du brouillard
dehors oh merci Dada le brouillard
le brouillard
le brouillard a tout mis dans son sac de
coton le brouillard a tout pris autour
de ma maison plus de fleurs au Jardin
plus d'arbres dans l'allée la serre du
voisin
semble s'être envolée et je ne sais
vraiment
où peut s'être posé le moineau que
j'entends si tristement fillah
ah notre petit cornichon est un poète
trop content les enfants je vous
remercie je suis le plus heureux de
nounours
Pépita il est l'heure de rentrer chez
toi oui je me sens et moi aussi
bien sûr en route bonsoir les amis
[Musique]
bonsoir amis à demain nounours
oh pas trop que le joie de revoir ses
amis tu es bien chargé nounours ce sont
les parfums de la montagne qu'ils m'ont
offert et que j'en porte ce qu'ils m'ont
Gotu les chéris allô en route mon bon
nounours bonne nuit les enfants allez
vite vous coucher et faites de beaux
rêves
[Musique]